Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where to lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the Round
Table of adequate lighting,
we're gonna be talking
about a number of things
including the witching hour.
Can we also talk about teleportation?
We're gonna be talking
about teleportation.
Okay.
We're gonna be talking
about the difference
between being murdered and assassinated.
We got lots of good questions from y'all.
Why are you using that voice though?
That's my new thing.
I'm trying to know,
I've been thinking a lot
but I got to keep listening.
Yeah.
It's easier to do than a
monster truck announcer voice.
It's easier to do than this
at the Dorton Arena.
Okay, it's easier to do than that.
Yeah.
You wouldn't think you
could get monster trucks
in the Dorton Arena having played there,
which if you don't know is the old venue
in the middle of the State
Fairgrounds in North Carolina
that we would always,
there'll be concerts during the Fair
and then we were one of the
concerts and it seems small.
How could you have,
I've never been to a monster truck rally.
That voice makes me not want to go but-
Really, that makes me wanna go.
Everything else makes me wanna go.
I think you want to be in a
place that feels too small
for monster trucks if you're
gonna go watch monster trucks.
Yeah.
Because you want the you wanna feel
the impending doom like this.
If Bigfoot loses control,
we could all die.
Like that's the fun in it.
Dig your own grave by going
and seeing Grave Digger.
Have you watched?
Not in a long time?
Okay, you have no idea.
Go on YouTube and just
type in monster truck.
I'm gonna see some big truck.
It's a totally new thing.
It'd be an elephant, could
be a truck, I don't care.
Monster Truck.
No type in monster truck highlights.
What they're doing in the
world of monster trucks
is so much crazier than
what they were doing
the last time you checked in.
When you checked in last time,
it was like Bigfoot was like
y'all could crush them cars.
Now Bigfoot and I don't even
know Bigfoot still around.
Can like balance on the back wheels.
Do a full flip.
What?
Link, it's basically like
watching an Olympic gymnast.
It's like Simone Biles.
But she's driving a truck.
But she's in a truck, she is the truck.
Oh, that's good.
You have no idea what they're doing
in the world of monster
trucks and I wanna go.
As soon as crowds happen again I'm going.
I think that statement just
applies across the board.
I want to go, I want to do, I want to see.
You have no idea.
Monster trucks sound like
the most amazing thing ever
because you've got a quarantine goggle.
I can't believe you don't know this.
I do remember.
I think Jenna went to
a monster truck rally.
Jenna didn't you go to
a monster truck rally?
I've been to a couple.
She's been to a couple.
She's on the video chat.
Hey, I'm I not right about
what they're doing is amazing?
She is watching us do this
because I mean, what
else does she have to do?
She's talking, they're amazing right?
Balancing on just the back wheels,
bouncing on the front wheels.
Yeah, balancing on the back wheels
just the front was a bunch of trickery.
Have they developed the technology?
There was a type of monster truck toy
that remote control
monster truck as a kid.
I don't know why you
said remote with an L.
Did I?
When you get at least like I said.
I say a lot of things wrong man I know
but you put out everything
the time I say it.
I say wolves with an L
too because it's in there.
You don't.
Wolf man.
Have they developed
the toy that I remember
as a child that was a monster truck
that whenever it would it
would get stuck on something
claws would come out.
Like animal claws would
come out of the wheel,
of the tires and then it would start
climbing over boulders and stuff?
What was the name of
that thing I had that.
You had it?
Oh yeah I had it.
In California or something
or when I was your friend?
When I was a kid I had the monster truck
that had the like orange
claws that came out.
Hands that came out and grip things.
I bet it was called the claw.
I don't know, I'm into do.
Do they do that?
I'm sure they doing something like that.
Jenna you've seen that?
No, I haven't seen the claws.
He hasn't seen the claws.
He hasn't seen claws.
That's advanced technology.
Well, when that happens,
I'm definitely going.
Okay.
I think it's like a fun loving girl venue.
I mean, Jenna has a fun loving girl.
I know that memory would go,
maybe heart would go to memory ghoster
I mean wrestling matches?
And putting on her hem.
It's monster truck,
yeah she's living it up.
She's totally living it up.
If I really wanted to have fun,
I'd really be friends with her.
Like active friends.
Like wait you know, we're passive,
digital friends, like if we see each other
but I guess that's one of the appeals.
She's fun love.
Yeah, well.
I don't know what she doing lately.
That's the thing.
When you live a life as exciting as memory
then when COVID happens, I
mean we should check in on her.
Because she's not going to see wrestling.
She's not going to see a monster truck.
I'm sure it's not the same when
you watch it on television.
I mean have you watched
wrestling, I watch.
I watched some of the
highlights on Dorton Mania
and there's no crowd of course.
I mean, sports without
crowd is already crazy,
already sort of weird.
Wrestling without crowds, I
mean, it's almost embarrassing.
Yeah.
Like when the guy hits
the lands on the mat
and you can really hear
it and nothing else.
So they're not adding crowd noise.
NBA games?
They have a crowded digital crowd.
They have a digital crowd
but they add crowd noise at certain parks.
Yeah, they do.
And it's fine.
The NBA games are still fun to watch.
I don't think they had
crowd noise the whole time.
They heard crowd noise at the beginning.
It's a transitional voice.
Transitional moments or whatever.
But then you get into the game
and I don't think there's crowd noise.
But you see the people on
the screens, are they live?
Like, are they video conferencing inn
or are they just sitting
in footage of themselves
as being live?
Oh, it's live.
So how do you get to be one of them?
I don't know, me and Lark
I've had this discussion.
I was like figure out how you become
one of those people who's watching.
And I gave him an assignment.
He didn't do it.
But I did find out,
I heard somebody talking
on Twitter about...
because I was wondering,
like people on video chats,
their decorum is a lot different
than somebody in the real world right?
The chances of you
literally whipping it out
on a video chat, as a joke are
way higher than in real life.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, you talking about
the twig and berries.
Yeah.
And you just know that somebody's like,
I'm gonna get on there and whip it out.
Yeah because now what are they gonna do?
Come to your house and-
I don't know what they're gonna do.
But I do know there's
two things that happen.
The first thing that happens is,
if somebody whips it out
or makes an obscene gesture
I think with it we could
expand what the different is.
You immediately kick them off
the stream and ban them right?
But then the second thing
is there is a slight delay
because one of the things you'll notice
if you watch the NBA games right now,
is there are these very long,
sometimes like seven to nine seconds long
where you don't hear anything
except the announcers
because they're bleeping out
the profanity of the players
that you typically do not
hear because of the crowd.
And these dudes are constantly cursing.
They're cursing a whole lot less
because they know they're
being listened to.
We just watched one of the
NBA games and they will just,
oh dope somebody cursing,
somebody cursing back.
All the audio drops out of the court.
So there's a delay, I don't
know what the delay is
seven seconds or whatever,
just in time for somebody to be like,
"Oh, they cursed I'm gonna."
So if you show a twig
berries in the field,
they can probably
automatically not show it.
There's some technology, you know.
So does that,
have you just talked
yourself out of pursuing,
being in the virtual state.
The way that I know that
is live is because if
again, I watched a lot of NBA.
And what's happening
now is like when people
like I saw the other day like Paul Pierce
was watching a Celtics game.
And he was in the crowd
watching a Celtics game.
And like they were showing his reactions
to things that were
happening and he was like...
They'll show people like
somebody misses a free throw
and you'll watch all the people
behind the goal like go...
And also when people are
shooting free throws,
they put the opposing teams feed.
Or maybe it just happened to be that.
And everybody's on their screens trying
to get the guy to miss.
Okay.
So you're saying they have a separate fee
than like the average viewer,
than the broadcast viewer
because theirs is actually live.
Well, but you Oh.
And then the thing that brought
seven seconds wouldn't work for us.
Well, it wouldn't work for them.
You would look like everybody was just
very slow and reacting to everything.
Probably, do have a real feed of the game
that is no delay for the special people.
And how did you get to
be one of those people?
I know you probably go to
nba.com is turning into an ad.
Yeah.
It's probably been a .com slash IR
and it will redirect you to
a site that actually exists.
Now, I was watching a
WNBA game the other day,
they do not do the crowd.
They have no video crowd.
And I was like, why don't
they get a video crowd?
They don't get a video crowd?
What's up with that?
Give the women a video crowd.
It's the same court right?
It's not the same court.
It's a court that looks the same.
The setup is similar.
It's a lot of screens, double the screens.
What are you trying to say?
That's probably their justification.
I'm not saying I agree with that.
Well, I know that there's a lot less money
in the WNBA than in the NBA
and maybe they just don't
have money for screens.
But it immediately hit me that like,
y'all need to do the screens
for the women as well.
Because it's this really
obvious difference.
Yeah.
I mean, how would you rate yourself?
I mean, we're talking quarantine.
Okay, on a scale of one
to 10 years in general.
Oh, you mean just how I feel right now?
Yeah.
I mean let's just have a
quick quarantine update,
just on a scale of one to 10.
Okay, coming back from
vacation. I had some low points.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, just, I don't know.
I just you know, something I told you
about the disappointing
thing that happened
on vacation would hurt myself or whatever.
But actually I had a moment of
like a very specific moment
during meditation last week,
where it was like, things
sort of shifted for me.
Ego death.
It was anything that substantial
but it was just one of
those things that was like,
well, no it was just sort of
a realignment of my expectations.
I saw a lowering of expectations.
Well, that would be a
negative way to put it.
But I do think that there is a,
we were talking about this this morning,
as a family we were talking about this.
But like, I think one of the things
that happens when you are stuck
and you're not able to travel
and you're not able to experience life
in the way that you used to.
If you're being a responsible person.
That is I mean, if you're not
being a responsible person,
you're just going on about your business,
then hey screw you and be you.
You won't be able to relate
to what I'm about to say.
But if you're being a responsible citizen
in the midst of this pandemic
and so you're limiting
yourself from the things
that you would typically experience,
you can in depending on your personality,
you can have a tendency to begin to,
you know, it's just depressing, right?
It's depressing.
It's the same thing over and over again.
And I was thinking about traveling
and I was thinking about all the things
that I want to experience
and I was listening to
a guided meditation.
And the woman doing the guided meditation-
Monster truck guided meditation.
There's an idea.
Write that down.
But now her voice was very, very peaceful,
very peaceful, and very soothing.
And she was basically talking
about your inner landscape,
as opposed to the
world's landscape, right?
And just this realization,
that sort of the work
that you do on yourself
by being introspective,
figuring yourself out
and sort of getting lost in
your own inner landscape.
And I don't mean that in like
a super self absorbed way.
I mean that in like becoming who you are,
becoming the process of
becoming who you're becoming,
is something that if you
are truly engaged in it,
it stands to be
substantially more fulfilling
than the idea of just exploring
the external world, right?
Because we tend to,
we were programmed in a way to think that
the external is where happiness is,
is something outside of you.
It's a new house, it's a new car,
it's a new jobs, it's a new relationship.
And everyone falls for this lie, right?
That if you get the circumstances,
the external circumstances
in your life right,
you will be happy.
But every single person
who has ever gotten
the external circumstances
completely right,
says this ain't it y'all.
This ain't it right?
Perfect example of that from,
if you relate to our
background, King Solomon, right?
Yeah.
The whole Ecclesiastes, the whole book
is about how I had everything
anything that I wanted,
any pleasure that I wanted
and it's all vanity right?
It's all, there's nothing
new under the sun it's not.
And so for me and I have to
come to this multiple times,
so I was thinking about my vacation
how it didn't go how I wanted it to.
Another thing again, these are
super first world problems,
very privileged problems.
I get back from a vacation
and my fricking pool area
still not done right?
Like they still got multiple things to do.
The pool has no water in it, et cetera.
These things that most people don't have,
period in the world or
even in the United States.
And I'm complaining because
mine's not done yet, you know?
But then I was like but why am
I placing so much expectation
and why I'm I relating my
happiness to the impending
completion of this project
because I already know
what's gonna happen.
The project is going to get done,
I'm going to have a pool and a hot tub
that are exactly the
way me and my wife want.
I'm gonna get in there.
I'm gonna listen to the music from
the speakers that we've installed.
And I'm going to be happy about
that for about four hours.
Now, we're gonna enjoy as a family,
I'm gonna to try not
to take it for granted.
But everyone adjusts your barometer,
your thermostat changes it
adjust to whatever you're in.
And so there was just this
moment where I was like,
what about right now?
What about the moment right now?
What about what's happening right now?
Find the joy and what's
happening right now.
Find the joy in figuring out who you are
and dealing with your own bullshit.
Did that happen?
Yeah, it did.
And I feel like I've been able to tap
into that for about a week.
So I feel good right now.
I'm sure it will wear off
and then I'll have to go
to a monster truck rally.
I was just asking for a number?
Nine.
Wow, okay.
That's a powerful nine
coming from everything
you've been thinking about.
What about you?
Yeah, I think,
I mean the vacation was really helpful
I mean if you're you
know like giving advice
but I know everyone can go on a vacation
or but there's just finding
something to look forward to
even if it's something small.
I got a wreck at the end.
It will make you happy?
I don't know, make some people happy,
made my family happy.
Yeah, I'm thinking about a
good solid eight right now.
That's a B+ in my book.
Oh, yeah that's I mean
'cause vacation was a good experience.
I think I was rejuvenated by that
and I had given myself
a little more leeway
to not put so much pressure on myself
and try and beat myself up
for what we're not able to do
or what what I'm not able to accomplish
or whatever but it
fluctuates very drastically.
Yeah.
And it's a couple of days at
a time and then you move to
you know, it's like you might
move to a more depressive zone
it just it hardly happens but there's
finding something to
do to to get out of it.
Like Christie's got, you know
not that we need more plants,
Oh, you always need more.
No, she's like, I'm getting more plants.
I'm getting my hands dirty.
It's like these type of things hell.
She's getting her hands dirty?
Like she's digging into the dirt.
Yeah.
Wow, like a farmer.
She is a farmer.
She's a farmer.
Does she have fruits?
We have lemons, that's a fruit.
It is a fruit.
We have pomegranates.
You have limes?
No.
You should have limes
because I was making
guacamole the other night.
And you have avocados,
you have avocado tree?
I have a grocery store.
Okay, yeah.
But what we didn't have
and this is every...
okay what is the key
ingredient besides avocados?
Now I probably have already given it away.
Onions.
So I mean a classic guacamole
is avocado, onions, salt and lime.
Right you can put some
peppers in there if you want.
Some people put tomatoes I
know you don't like to do that.
I don't even put tomatoes in my guacamole
because it makes it too runny
unless it's a really good tomato.
But if you use the lime juice
that's in the plastic lime
and that sucker is
older than a week or so.
The tongue is gone and
we had so many avocados
because Jesse does something where
there's like some local farm
who brings produce or whatever, you know.
And we had like 12 avocados
because we had a batch that came in
and we didn't touch them.
And then we had a new batch come in,
I have a baby we got to have guacamole.
We gotta have guacamole
multiple nights in a row.
And so I was like,
I'm going for a full
avocado bowl right now.
Which is a lot of guacamole.
Get the chips to support that.
Not really, man.
I was really loading up the chips
because I didn't have the
ratio right for that either.
There's some toast too.
I was also putting it on a Quesadilla.
Oh, that's good.
I'm using that guy fee
Eddie, guy fee Eddie,
guy fee Eddie is what I say now.
Salsa that we we had on the show
and boy that sauce is good man.
You like it?
Yeah, that's smoking pepper.
Smokey.
But anyway.
What are we talking about?
The tongue of the guacamole is the key
and I didn't have the tang,
I just felt like a fool.
With this really dull lime juice
is like no matter how much I put in there
from that dull dead lime juice,
plastic green lime thing.
So in other words you
should have a lime tree
I'll come get some when
I'm making guacamole.
Lando and I are gonna remove
the rocks from the rock tumbler.
That's happening tonight.
How long has that been going?
Since before vacation.
Constantly moving?
Yeah, we went really
overboard on the polish stage.
There's three different
phases, three different grits.
Yeah, but like we did an experiment where
we left the Polish stage on there
for like a week longer than we should.
But what can hurt?
What can hurt?
You're gonna break the rocks?
Exactly, so now we're excited.
We're gonna open that thing up tonight.
Send me some pictures.
That's what I'm looking forward to.
Oh, I will take them, I'll take pictures.
I take progress photos of the rocks
before and after every state .
Oh, when you put this on your Instagram?
This is exciting content.
You get a lot of followers doing that.
Yeah, it is.
It could just be only a rock tumbler site.
Alright, let's get into some questions.
So we're doing good.
Let's ride that way, join us.
You know, if you don't, if you're a four
if you're a three if you're
a one right now, it's okay.
I'll be there next week again probably
and just make up your mind
to tumble some rocks figuratively.
And just let let the process work.
Yes, okay.
We're gonna get into the questions.
But first, we're gonna remind you
that you can go to our little website
that we put together on mythical.com.
Mythical.com.
We sell all kinds of things
there and the thing that
we have brought back,
multiple times we brought
back this my favorite design
ever related to Good Mythical Morning
and that is the sunrise.
T now we it was a sweatshirt at one point.
So it's like, it says
Good Mythical Morning
and it's got like a sunrise thing.
Like sun coming over the horizon.
This shirt is black now.
It's a different week.
Yeah, we've done it as a
sweatshirt and like teal
or whatever that color
was and then a T-shirt.
And now we brought it
back as a black T-shirt.
You're gonna like it.
Oh, I love it.
I almost wore it today.
You should have.
I didn't know about the timing.
Because you know, I've had it for a while.
I didn't wanna spoil anything too soon.
We give the mythical
society like a sneak preview
and I didn't wanna circumvent
that but I was wrong.
It's out, check it out mythical.com.
Also, subscribe to this YouTube
channel that you're watching
and listening to your biscuits on.
Yeah.
Click that bell.
It's so easy.
Just do it right now.
It doesn't cost anything.
Just go ahead and do it.
Just a reminder that we're
here for you every week.
Do you have something against it?
Just a reminder that we are
here for you every week.
Do you have something against subscribing?
Just go ahead and subscribe.
We're not gonna bombard you.
Who knows what we're gonna say.
You'll just know when we're back.
Okay Tavin Mascari asks,
at what time of night do you consider
to be the cutoff of late
night and early morning?
So you go downstairs and
your kid is up at 3 am
do you say, what are you doing up so late?
Or what are you doing up so early?
#EarBiscuits
3 am and I'm not even
gonna go into any sort of,
I'm not gonna ask myself why I think this
but just 3 am middle of
the night, late night.
That's, the middle of the night is not.
I mean, yeah technically midnight.
We all know that let's
just set the baseline
at 12 it's am,
the the middle of the night
is the first of the next day.
Can we agree on that?
Yeah, that's not the
question at hand but yes.
I don't consider that would
be the middle of night
but 3 am is kind of late
like the middle of the night.
No, that's not the question.
Do you Consider the middle of night
that we're not finding
the middle of the night.
You just said you considered
3 am the middle of the night.
Right but what I meant was-
That's a little late.
It's three.
I'm okay, forget middle of
the night, it's the night.
Like, if you're up at
3 am, you're up late.
For me, if you're up at
4 am, you're up early.
That's the cut off.
That's how, in my brain
without thinking about it.
If I wake up at 4:30, I think to myself,
damn, I wake up so early.
If I wake up at 3:30 I think
why I'm I waking up in
the middle of night?
Now that's a good test because
his example is not helpful
because I think if you
haven't gone to sleep,
then it's still the night.
You can't have a morning
until you go to sleep
unless the sun comes up.
So as long as the sun's not up
and you haven't gone to
sleep, it is still night.
I don't disagree with you,
but that is I do not believe
that is Tavans question.
The implication is that
you've gone to sleep.
If Tavan has gone to sleep
to sleep and he wakes up,
but if I go downstairs at 2 am,
the kids might still be awake.
I've never done three.
Sometimes I've stayed up till
two but if I've woken up,
I understand but they
haven't gone to sleep.
I would not ask them
why are you up so early?
Because they haven't gotten up?
But also it's 2 am, forget the kid.
No, I'm saying his example doesn't work
for me either way.
Okay, what about this example?
But you wake up at night,
you look at the clock.
It says 3:30 do you think,
damn what I'm I waking up in
the middle of the night for?
I'm using I understand.
To me, I think it's later
I think it's, I would say-
What do you wake up at 4:30?
You wake up at five o'clock.
More of 5:30.
Okay, so for somebody who wakes up at 5:30
and I used to pre COVID I woke up at 5:50
now I wake up at 630.
So I think to me it would be 4:30.
So 4:20 is-
Is still night.
Is that really night?
That's morning for me,
because I can think of
many different times
when they're like, I gotta go on a trip.
We'll be going to the airport,
we got to get up at four o'clock.
And when I think then I'm like,
damn that's gonna be early morning
but if I had to get up at
three o'clock I'm like,
I'm not going to sleep.
Yeah, for me, it's that the four to five.
Okay, well where I was
trying to get to this
I was hoping that you would
agree with a three to four
because I think that there
is a subconscious connection
to what is known as the witching hour,
which is traditionally
understood to be 3 am to 3:59am.
I did not know that.
So that's what the witching hour is.
Now people kind of
disagree and first of all,
is the witching hour even a thing
but most people agree
that, that is the hour
that has the highest
supernatural activity, right?
Okay.
People who believe in
supernatural paranormal things
tend to think, that's what
they call the witching hour.
Three o'clock to 3:59.
I didn't do much reading
about this other than
to establish that I didn't like find out
like what's that about?
But I just found an interesting that
that hour is where there's
the most extreme activity
and for me is that in my mind is the hour
in which the transition
between night and day
is actually happening, which is weird.
Based on what, just your gut?
Yes based on my gut, yeah, like I said,
if it's four o'clock, I feel
like why I'm I up early?
If it's 3:30 I'm like, why I'm I up late?
Again, I'm not analyzing it.
I'm just saying from the gut,
that's what it feels like.
But again, I like to
entertain the possibility
of sort of weird believing weird things.
It's been proven in my life,
to be fun to believe weird things.
And I think it's been
proven throughout history
that it's fun and attractive
to believe were things.
It's fun to believe conspiracy theories.
It's fun to believe in
supernatural things.
It makes life more interesting,
whether it's true or not.
I think it's fun to read about it
and other people who believe it
but I don't have to go so far to say
it's fun to actually
believe it, might be sad.
Well, it depends on what the implicate
what the affecting your
personal life is, I guess.
But what I'm saying and maybe it's scary.
At that time at night.
That's an interesting moment.
I mean, there's you
can, it's a sneaky time.
It's the least active time,
you can get away with the most
but there's the least amount to do.
Unless you're gonna I guess what, witch?
Well I think, here's the scientific.
And again when I say
scientific it's in quotes
and has an asteroid next to it
because it's coming from me
and so it's not qualified.
But it could sound qualified
to maybe a person who's not that smart.
I think that while again,
it's fun to believe
that there's actual
paranormal things happening.
If I'm putting on my rational hat,
I think nah doesn't really happen.
It's perception and it's
based on people's patterns,
and what state your brain in
the world is at that time.
And I just happen to believe that
and again I have no
science to back this up.
There's something about your
susceptibility to seeing things
and misinterpreting things at that hour,
based on just our
circadian rhythms, right?
Because you've been asleep.
I was gonna say just based
on darkness and tiredness.
Well, darkness is a huge part of it
and yeah I mean that's another
way of saying the same thing.
If you get up, if you've
gone to sleep, right?
If you stay up to the witching hour,
I don't know if they're going
to have the same effect.
I mean, you'll be getting sleepy
and maybe your perception will be-
I think it might be worse,
you're prone to hallucination perhaps.
You're a person who you've
never had the opportunity
to see this but Link
is a very deep sleeper
and he is a very like he
will be very disoriented
upon waking right?
I'm a light sleeper and if you wake me up,
I might as well be ready to
take the SAT like I am full.
I go straight to 100, I'm fully aware
I'm not groggy, I'm talking normal.
I'm not happy about it.
I wish I slept deeper
and it would be probably more enjoyable.
But Link there is at least
two to three minute stupor
that you have Have to kind of get past
before you're fully there, right?
Well, especially if it's
at that time of night.
Yeah and I'm saying that
for me that time of night,
it might as well be the morning
I might be like, why I'm I awake?
But I'm also like, give me
a cognitive test right now.
No, that's an elephant.
But I think that most people are in like
a hindered state of awareness.
You're also like coming out of a dream,
your minds in a weird place.
You're gonna see and hear
and experience things.
And like you said, it's dark.
And so your mind is
gonna play tricks on you.
You're gonna see things in the dark,
no one else is there to confirm
or deny the things that you see,
of course you're gonna have
a bunch of weird stories
from that hour.
And then over the years is gonna develop.
Well, that's the witching hour.
That's where the paranormal
activity is the highest.
That's my theory.
So back to back to the question.
I mean, we've already
answered the question.
We're only off by an hour by the way.
Yeah, but I think it's a
pretty significant hour.
And I was missing the witching hour.
And I would think the interesting thing
is you go to bed so early
and you get up so early.
It's weird to me that your
perception of the morning
is all the way into four o'clock.
That's strange to me.
You go to bed at 9:30
because it's a minimal impact
to me to get up at 4:30 an hour earlier
but if you're buying plane
tickets back when that happened,
and you're like, "Okay, I got it
"yet I got to work
backwards from arriving."
That means we got to
wake up at 4 am versus,
I mean, psychologically waking up at 5 am
versus four anything is a lot worse
But three, like I'll
buy a plane ticket if-
And I would have never
bought a plane ticket
to get up at three.
Precisely that you're
confirming my argument.
Or four.
Okay, I've done that.
I've plenty of times.
We've had a flight where
if you got a flight at
seven o'clock at LAX
you gotta get up at four
something to get there.
You can't get up at five.
And I'm like you know what?
I'm not getting up before
five, I just can't do that.
Okay, that's fine.
But what I'm saying is,
most early morning flights
are in the seven something.
And given how long it takes to get to LAX
and how busy it is.
You got the family.
You got to get the family up.
You got to get up at four something.
But I never have gotten the
family up at three something.
We will not do that in our household.
Because that's the witching
hour, you might see a ghost.
Oh, that's why?
Julia 483 asks,
if teleportation was
possible, how would it work?
How would we be able to do that on our own
or would we need some devices?
How expensive would it be?
And how would they stop
people from teleporting
to places that they
should not teleport to?
Lots of questions about
teleportation Julia,
you thinking a lot about this?
So this is a deep
constitution of your molecules
and then a skipping
through space and time.
So impossible.
And then a reconstitution of molecules.
We're talking tricky in situation here.
I have a more formative
question about this.
That makes makes the the
thought exercise that Julia
is inviting us to partake
in even more complicated
because teleportation is
my superpower of choice
because I believe that it is
basically equivalent to flight
regardless of the nature of it,
because if I could choose
between flight or teleportation,
I would choose teleportation.
Because I could basically just teleport
like an infinite number of
times and that's my flight
or I could just be the guy
who like teleports 100 yards
and then falls in like
a wing squirrel suit
and then teleports again
and spoil some more
and then teleports a little bit higher,
you know like I'm constantly flying.
It's like I just doing it
in like the stratosphere.
Yes.
But here's the thing.
And this is the question-
Aerial teleporting.
This is the question for time travel to
and I don't know when this first hit me
and I know that people
will probably discuss it.
This is not a novel thing.
But how do you,
what is the point of reference
in terms of your locality?
When you're teleporting
or time traveling, right?
So how okay, let's just take
back to the future, right?
So we forget when we
think about time travel
and we think okay well, Marty
McFly has got to go back
to this exact place in this exact time
and he's still going to be
in the town that he was in.
Okay, literally, he's
driving down the road
in the middle of the town.
And then when he travels in time,
he's driving down the same
road in the same town.
And that's because in our world,
our point of reference is the world
but the world we are on a sphere.
If you believe that and we are traveling,
not only are we spinning but
we're traveling around the sun,
which is also moving
through in our galaxy.
What is the point of reference
for time travel or teleportation?
Everything's moving so quickly.
How did Doc Brown figure out
how to have the car come back.
The points of reference,
the Earth would be in a
completely different place in 1985
than it wasn't 1955 like
not, there would be so
it would be so far from where it was.
So did his machine have a way to like,
locate where the Earth would be?
Sure it was relative.
I mean, I think he wrote it.
It's not possible.
It's relative to the center of the Earth.
So I think he wrote it
all on a chalkboard.
But okay, so in reality like I don't know.
This as easy as writing
a script by the way.
They said, they being
some people on the news
who talk about what
scientists come up with,
they set some particle back in time,
like last year or something, right?
How?
Like they, I don't know.
No, they didn't.
Yeah, they did but not
like way back in time.
They made a particle slip off
of the timeline a little bit.
I'm using non scientific terms
for what actually happened.
Okay.
But it that's a particle moving
a very, very very small
amount of time, right?
I don't even really
understand the nature of it.
I'll be getting this wrong.
But like, let's say a human moved a year,
you got to be in fricking
space man like if you move
at four and at least you're gonna
to be in a different country.
And also not on the surface,
you're gonna be in the Earth's crust,
you're gonna be in the
center of the earth,
you're gonna be on the top of a mountain,
you're gonna be way high
you but most likely,
you're gonna be outside of
the paper thin atmosphere
of the Earth and no longer present.
You're gonna be in the middle
of space, if you time travel,
unless they have a point of reference
for being in that exact locality.
But what is the point of reference
if the universe is constantly expanding?
And depending on where you're,
well, no matter where
you are in the universe,
you will seem like you're in
the center of the universe.
That's one of the understandings of
the way that space and time is expanding
is that you can go anywhere
you want to in the universe
and you always perceived
to be in the middle of it.
So there's no point of reference.
It's all relative.
You talked me out of wanting to do it.
So the first guy who's
gonna be like, I'm doing it.
I'm time traveling.
Hopefully they're like, hold on a second.
You're not gonna end up here again dude,
you're gonna die so don't do it.
And the same is true with teleportation.
Unless it's like the kind of teleportation
where you're oh, you can only
teleport where you can see,
which I think is, there was some movie
where that was the case.
And I don't know why that was the rule.
But you could only teleport
where you could see.
Sounds safer.
And then that point,
you'd have to worry about
if you're moving instantly
and you move into a place you can see
so I think that you need like,
it's not gonna be a problem.
But anyway, that's something
that complicates the question for me.
Too complicated for me, Julia.
I got nothing.
Josh West asks how
important do I have to be
to be assassinated and not murdered?
First of all Josh,
I want to just send my condolences
for your untimely demise.
But I have to point out
that it probably has something to do
with your Twitter handle,
with a handle like at start of the West.
He's trying to be important.
Yeah, I think you're trying a bit too hard
and it is gonna backfire
with probably some form of a murder.
So watch out for yourself.
Take self defense class.
He might be the start of the West.
I mean do you know,
do you think you are
the start of the west?
I just think that-
I've never heard of her.
And I haven't heard of Josh
and I think If either one existed,
well, I think Josh exists.
But if Kyle existed I think
I would have heard of Josh.
There's a lot of things that
exist that are at least,
going by what my oldest son says to me.
That are really important
and really popular
that I don't know about.
So start of the West
may be one of the things
that is a big deal in the West.
What if it is, then he's
got the Twitter handle.
But I think the distinction
between assassination and
murdering is simply political.
Think of the most popular
non political person on Earth right now.
Some pop star or some athlete, right?
Yeah.
If LeBron James and again,
not speaking anything into existence here.
If LeBron James were killed,
you wouldn't say LeBron
James is assassinated
because he's Had a political figure.
I think that they refer to
john Lennon's assassination.
Well, that shrink.
I'm gonna throw out a
couple of things here.
That's strange to me, is that true?
I think just google john Lennon's,
well, first of all bias Google
john Lennon's assassination
and just see if it's a thing.
Because to me the factors are,
if you're killed for an ideological reason
or to prevent you from
accomplishing something
on some on some scale,
then I think we might be
in assassination territory.
Well.
Or if it's done by,
I was gonna say if it's
done by professional
but a hit on somebody
is not an assassination.
Well, the wiki entry is
the murder of John Lennon,
Does it say assassination?
Did you Google what I asked you?
I did, I said John Lennon assassination
and the thing that was suggested
was John Lennon assassin,
so that the person who
committed it, this okay
someone who kills a public figure.
If an assassin is an assassin
you were assassinated.
I actually think there's a distinction.
So what's an assassin is someone who-
Kills a public figure.
A public figure?
Somebody who kills a public figure
in like a calculated way.
Not like somebody who kills a
public figure in like a fight.
So an assassin can murder somebody
or assassinate somebody.
But he's called a perpetrator on Wiki
and again, Wiki is the
source for all truth.
Murder, resuscitation attempt.
Oh, this is this is-
1980.
Again, I just think you have
to be a political figure.
So obviously, like if the
CIA goes to a foreign land
and kills a leader of a country,
that's an assassination.
If somebody kills a
political leader of any kind,
that's an assassination.
Now, if you're like a city councilman.
Google define assassination.
Well, let's figure it out first.
Because I think that like that probably.
If you're like the president of the PTA.
That's a murder.
You know, if you're like the
head of the school board,
even in a big city, what is the cutoff?
If you're a mayor, that's an assassination
unless you're like a Mayor.
School board is elected.
So as an elected official,
I think if an elected official is killed
and there's an ideological reason
or to prevent them from doing something
it's a low scale assassination.
If who does what?
I think if you-
Assassination is the act
of assassinating someone.
Okay, we got it.
I think Josh if you
want to be assassinated
and not murdered you just
need to join the school board.
Things get heated.
Well in Okay, this is not.
You need to be a political figure
is I think what we're arriving at.
This is diff sense.com.
I don't know where that is.
When used as nouns assassination means
the murder of a person
especially for political reasons
or for personal gain.
So if you like killed someone
to get an insurance policy,
no, that's not assassination
whereas murder means
inactive deliberate killing
of another being especially.
How important do you have to be?
You have to be an elected official.
It says assassination is the
act of deliberately killing
a prominent person such as a head of state
or head of government and
assassination may be prompted
by political and military motives.
But give me an example.
We need an example.
Of just like an athlete
being assassinated.
Was Martin Luther King
Junior assassinated?
Definitely, 100% that's assassination?
I know it was because he's a leader.
He was the leader of a political movement.
Yeah.
He's a leader of a political movement.
He wasn't an elected official
but it was a political.
Yeah.
It could be described as a political move.
So I come up with another example then.
If an athlete or a pop
star is doing something,
if they're killing it.
Ideological Bill Gates,
that's what he did.
So he's a philanthropist.
I don't know if that would
be an assassination though.
He's doing he's doing all this.
He's doing all this work
unless you believe the conspiracies.
He's doing all this work.
He's doing all this work to give everybody
the mark of the beast
through the vaccination,
that's what he is doing because
it's fun to believe that.
To help people.
So if he's murdered in
order to prevent that,
then that's an assassination.
But again that's socio political.
It's a social thing.
Yeah.
Now the state of the West again-
Congratulations on the title.
Let me discover things about this
stud implies prominence
importance, coolness,
probably good lookingness.
West implies...
West implies a region
to the left of the Rockies.
Yeah,
By the left of the Mississippi.
Mississippi because I
mean east of the Rockies
is still technically the West, yeah.
But the West implies a
geopolitical in my mind,
when you say the West I think he's talking
about the American West.
So this is a geopolitical title.
The stud of the West is like
the best looking coolest,
most athletic dude in
this geopolitical region
and as you know-
What is he doing?
If you're good looking,
if you're a good athlete,
the chances of becoming
a prominent politician,
leading a political movement go way up.
So I would say, yeah
Josh if you're killed,
it will be clearly an assassination.
Just by virtue of your Twitter handle.
At lexer, Hello Alexandra.
Oh, what are the chances
that this was not planned?
I'm wearing the pin that Alexandra made
for me of Barbara's face.
This is how you wear that a lot.
I haven't worn on the
podcast in a long time
and we're taking whatever questions.
Does everyone have a
voice inside their head
when they're writing or reading?
Is that what my voice actually sound?
Is that what my voice
actually sounds like?
Or is this what I think
my voice sounds like?
Is it even my voice?
I don't know if if I relate to this
because I do not have a voice
that I'm hearing when I'm reading.
I just feel like I'm
taking the words directly
to the language center of my brain.
And I don't feel like I'm
translating them into a voice
unless I'm reading a fictional book,
at which point the character may adopt
some sort of voice image in my mind
but if I'm just reading
words like reading this.
Or an autobiography, you hear
the person who's reading it
like when I was talking
about the flee autobiography,
I hear him.
Of course.
Especially because of his writing style.
But yeah, right.
But if you're just reading like an email.
An email?
Do you hear the person?
well see this is it.
Well he's asking if you hear yourself
reading it out loud to yourself?
Because he's like, is that my voice?
Is this what my voice sounds like
or do I have a special
inside my head voice?
Let me just read some stuff here silently.
As well, now that you're thinking about it
now it's impossible.
Now that I'm thinking about
it, I'm hearing my voice.
Yeah, reading it to me.
Yeah, because you're manifesting that.
But if you if you hadn't been,
it just like don't think
of a pink elephant.
What do you think of?
A suitcase.
You thought of a pink elephant?
So you can't do this.
You can't say what I thought of.
You're telling me you didn't
just picture a pink elephant.
I deliberately didn't.
But you'd ride behind that
suitcase was a pink elephant.
If flash for a second and
I put it in a suitcase.
Right, which is the same
thing that's happened in here.
I can safely say that just
normal reading of words.
And also, I mean let's just translate this
just to thoughts in general.
Like when you're thinking
through something,
are you like you know,
your brain is processing
information most of the time
and you're making a
decision whether or not
you're translating that into
the English language, right?
Because the English
language is just a proxy
for some things that are
happening in the world, right?
It's just an interpretation but it isn't.
It doesn't actually
mean anything directly.
It just represents meaning.
Well, definitely when I'm
to take one step back.
When I'm writing something.
I mean, definitely an email
when I'll write an email.
I'll write it like I'm
saying it, for the most part
but I think that's a, it's a style choice.
Not everybody does that.
Some people, you know
you can hear some people
more than others in their emails.
Okay.
Because some people just
they have a writing style.
I'm not much of a writer.
So I think that's what
really come why I do that,
I'm more of a verbal processor.
So when I write something
down to communicate it,
I write down what I would
say, that we're there
and then if I get in my head
I'll like edit it like crazy.
But when you think.
But when I think.
Are you like because to me
if I'm really thinking hard.
I'm not hearing a voice in my head no.
There are times because
I feel like most people
are thinking about
multiple things at once.
And then if you like really focus,
you might be able,
I can generate an actual sort of like,
this is the voice saying the thing
like you should do this,
almost I'm saying or whatever.
But and this is why it's
gonna be really difficult
to ever invent the like
mind reading device.
Think about all the things
that have to happen.
Like you have to find a way to
interpret someone's thoughts
and then translate them
into a coherent speech
but that's not even
happening in their brain.
So how it how's that going to
happen outside of their brain?
I'm sure there's studies
where you can monitor
the language center of the
brain when somebody is reading
and I bet you there's
plenty of people right now
who are listening to thinking.
I definitely hear a voice
when I read and when I mean,
I've said that I hear my voice
when I write, more often.
But I guess that you don't know.
No, I'm saying I can activate that
like now that I'm thinking about it.
Like if you're writing
an email versus a script,
when you write the email,
do you do you hear yourself?
Not until I read it back.
When you read it back?
But now when you're writing it.
Now when I'm evaluating,
How does this come across?
At that point, I might hear a voice.
But I do think that's interesting
because I think that regardless of how
Elon Musk's neural link,
what is that going to do?
I think at best, we're gonna be able to
sort of generate
interpretations of emotions
like this person is angry.
This person is lying, this
person is turned on right now.
But this person is thinking
this specifically, no way.
But you but you could probably have,
in addition to the the
way that the brain centers
are being highlighted, some sort of AI
that gives a pretty
predictable interpretation
of what somebody is thinking.
But it won't be like and here's
the Senate's related to it.
But you'll be but you'll just know,
based on the question that you're asking
or the interpretation that the
conversation they're having.
What they would be saying
and maybe there's some robot
that could like put it into almost words.
digest.bps.org.uk says,
the websites that we pull up
Well when you Google it is you know,
it's the first thing that comes up
a new paper published in psychosis.
I love that magazine.
Suggest Most people do hear
an internal voice when they're reading.
For those who heard
different inner voices,
these tended to vary based
on the voice of the character
who was speaking in a story.
Or if it was a text message or email
on the voice of the sender.
And like I said I relate to that.
Hearing voices in your head
more than 80% of readers
have inner voice but not everyone
shares the same narrator.
While silently reading a book text message
or this article to yourself,
a voice may emerge from
the back of your mind
to narrate the sentences 80%.
Okay, I'm not saying I don't believe that.
But I have to believe
that this slows you down.
Like taking the time to
turn it into a voice.
Doesn't that make it?
Like what about people who speed read?
No, I don't do that.
But there's people who like you can't,
you know what I'm saying that
you gotta let go of the voice I think.
You gotta let go of the voice?
Find a way just to read just
to let it go directly to your brain.
I'm not convinced.
I mean, you don't think you
do but maybe you do 80%.
I said I do when I'm reading something
where it's like a character
voice or whatever, you know?
Or it might be, but it's not
but maybe I'm misinterpreting this.
Are you saying that it's
like the entire thing is being spoken
by somebody that you're
hearing in your head?
Or is it just like oh, I
got an email from Link.
I'm loosely associating the words
that I'm reading on this page
with the way that he would say them.
But it's not a process that
so fine tune that like,
he might as well be
inside my head speaking.
Like that has not happened to me.
Yeah, I'm kind of twisted
'cause every single time I get an email,
like if I don't know the
person I've got an email from
or if I'm reading an article,
I think I only hear a voice
when I know who it is.
Exactly and even then
what I'm saying is that
it's like a touch and go kind of thing.
I get lost in it and
eventually move beyond
the person's voice just to the content.
See, I'm reading this
freaking article right now
and I'm hearing myself read it to myself.
I gotta go back to that.
Yeah, I can turn it off.
It's very comforting.
What does the person sound like?
Me?
You really stumped us here, Alexandra.
Well, we've been stumped
left and right here today
but it's been fun.
It's kinda like indulging
in a conspiracy theory.
And I wonder if listening
to all audiobooks,
which I do more and more
makes this more likely or less likely.
You would think that it
has to make it more likely.
You know, you just get into this place
where I'm just taking in
books as people's voices only.
It seems like the easy study is somebody,
you hook somebody's brain
up and you let them read
and then you let them
listen to somebody talk
and see if the same part
of the brain lights up.
You know it's within the
language center, I don't know.
Let's do that.
Thanks for making us
think about this stuff.
What, I'm exhausted.
You know sometimes that's
all you can do is just think.
You know, you're stuck at home.
You're not going out to the restaurants.
You're not hugging people,
hadn't seen your parents.
Just trying to go within
yourself and discover something.
Just listen to that little voice
that you hear constantly
while you're reading.
Or go outside and play
with something you bought.
Wreck time.
Wreck baby, wreck baby,
one, two, three, four.
When we were at the beach,
I was reminded of this thing
this game that exists,
that I'd forgotten about
that I knew about Spike Ball.
It's beaver popular now,
everybody's playing it.
So you saying this isn't much of a wreck?
No, no, I'm just saying it is
the game of choice on the beaches now.
Yeah it's the new corn hole for the beach.
Is that the name of it?
I didn't know the name of it.
Spike Ball.
Spike Ball?
So it's like a hula hoop
with a net stretched,
reasonably taut over it
and then it's got four legs
and you got this little ball
and you just bend it down.
Like serve it, bounce
it off and then you can-
Volleyball rules.
Yeah, volleyball.
Then you can hit it twice to yourself
and then hit it back over.
If you're just playing against somebody
at least that's how we're
doing it at our house.
Oh, you have done the four way game?
I have not mobilized four people
in my family to all participate at once.
I watched a four way game
at the beach on vacation.
That seems the most fun.
And I surmised it was,
you could not touch it twice yourself.
That was like volleyball, you
had to hit it to your partner.
I mean, it's Lincoln and Lando play.
You know, even with the age discrepancy,
they have a good time playing it.
So it's better than tetherball?
Yeah, it's better than tetherball.
If you're thinking about getting
a tetherball, don't Okay?
It needs to die.
Tetherball needs to go.
We have one.
Yeah and have you used it?
Well, there was a poll
that we would walk to
and hook it up.
Yeah, and was last time you did that?
I can't even remember.
Tetherball only exists as a joke.
We stopped when it jammed
the crap out of my finger.
Tetherball is just accident waiting.
Spike ball, you can get one on Amazon
for less than 30 bucks a whole set.
That's a pretty good deal.
You know if you play five
times you pay for the thing.
Why?
"cause you charge $6 every time?
Yeah.
Oh, thought you said $15
or $30, you said $30.
$30.
Okay, yeah six, I was
right the first time.
Yeah.
So hey, try it out, even with
just two people is still fun.
And then it's lightweight,
you can take it to the beach.
It can't fit.
I don't think maybe if it's
in a carrier, I don't know.
But it does fit in a carrier
because I was on a beach
that you had to like
walk down the steps to get to it.
I don't know, I think
my $30 one does have.
And the guy had it in like a backpack
and he broke it out and I was
like Well, okay here we go.
Try out Spike ball.
If you get someone who likes
to knock balls with you.
It seems to be much more
enjoyable when you're intoxicated
just based on my experience
watching the game.
It's also harder when you're
holding a beer in one hand.
I think my kids would concur.
Okay, Spike ball, Spike it up.
Yeah, look at that.
Social distance.
Anything to get these kids
doing something outside for a few minutes?
Hell, you can do that inside.
Oh, you could do it inside yeah.
It gets kind of out of control.
I wouldn't do that.
Don't do it outside.
Don't do it inside for me.
Do it outside.
Just Just let me finish.
That's it, do it outside.
Okay.
As long as you're not alone.
Let us know what you thought
about the discussion this week
#EarBiscuits
you probably know something we don't
'cause you're just really.
Give us the real science,
give us the real science on Twitter,
the source of all truth.
I wanna know if you hear a voice.
Let's talk about that specifically,
that's an interesting one.
#EarBiscuits talk at you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.